[Music]
battling to control The Inferno across
Spain it's a Race Against Time to
contain wildfires that have been raging
out of control from the south of the
country to the north where blazes have
scorched 4 600 hectares of land over the
past few days
train Journeys also thwarted by the
worst wildfires for a decade
in a visit to one of the worst affected
areas Spain's prime minister Pedro
Sanchez made clear what he thought was
to blame
I want to say that evidently climate
change kills it kills people kills the
ecosystem the biodiversity and it also
destroys the most precious Goods of our
society which is affected by these
wildfires homes businesses and livestock
we're here in a farming area in an
agricultural area near the town of
Zamora one of the worst affected parts
of Spain where the wildfires have been
raging for days and we've seen truly
apocalyptic scenes the Flames are just
taking over suddenly entire areas of
Farmland entire buildings filled with
animals and farming equipment people are
trying to use Harvesters to dig fire
lines to stop the fire where it is but
it continues to rage on and take over
more and more land just using it as fuel
burning further and faster
in Southwest France firefighters were
using every means at their disposal
including controlled burning a tactic
used to clear out the buildup of
flammable materials by igniting the
surrounding vegetation
and it is a matter of urgency since
Tuesday the blazes have already consumed
thousands of hectares of forest in the
gurond region
and thousands of residents and tourists
alike forced to move to Emergency
Shelters
amid all this is the uncomfortable
reality of the effect of record-breaking
high temperatures
as delegates from 40 countries gathered
at the Petersburg climate dialogue in
Berlin the message from the hosts
act now before it's too late
and while we are still grappling with
the Fallout from the pandemic the
impacts of climate change are becoming
even more dangerous across the world
threat that risk spilling out Beyond
countries directly affected
Al Jazeera Zamora Spain